alright some of you have heard some of
you haven't heard and some of you've
heard way too much I can tell you anyway
now writable Ferris office holding a
video contest where you have to make a
15-second video intro for the videos now
all the entries are in and that comes
the time to vote so I need your help
here and if I win this is what I get now
here's how you vote I need as many
people as I can get to click this link
down here once you click this length is
this my submission you need to rate it
five stars and I because that's how
they're doing things they go by the
average rating and then they go by how
many people voted for that video and it
should be so cool i had that because I
mean who wouldn't want to have it and I
put it on my videos I make more videos
like the district nine short film made
with Brett and it should be awesome and
when I hit about a thousand subscribers
I'm going to make a little contest of my
own some sweet prizes and that'd be
awesome as well oh yeah vote for me
please and I might make a couple intros
for you guys if I win and that'll be
awesome too so I mean hey we all win